este documento publicado por la oficina
de la dirección de inteligencia de eeuu
este 26 de febrero reavivó las tensiones
por el caso de yamaha jog y el informe
que señala al príncipe heredero saudita
mohamed bin salman de haber aprobado la
operación para acabar con la vida del
reportero de 59 años indica que el
control absoluto de las organizaciones
de inteligencia y seguridad del reino
hacen que sea altamente improbable que
funcionarios sauditas pudieran asesinar
a giorgi sin la autorización de bin
salman sin embargo no se emitieron
sanciones contra el príncipe solo
restricciones de visado contra 76
sauditas señalados de estar implicados
en amenazas a disidentes en el
extranjero esto como parte de una nueva
política conocida como la prohibición
hazoury que busca rendición de cuentas
para quienes ataquen a disidentes y
periodistas
creo que el informe habla por sí mismo y
creo que hoy se han visto una serie de
pasos muy importantes para recalibrar la
relación
en primer lugar la publicación del
informe en sí y la transparencia que
proporciona este es un informe que en
cierto sentido no está recién salido de
la imprenta lo publicamos y estábamos
decididos a brindar transparencia sobre
este tema y compartir con el pueblo
estadounidense lo que sabemos estimar
qué tipo
bobina en reacción a la publicación del
informe la relatora especial de la onu
sobre ejecuciones extrajudiciales señaló
que ahora eeuu debe tomar la iniciativa
para garantizar la rendición de cuentas
sobre el crimen pido al gobierno de
arabia saudita que revele si sus restos
fueron destruidos en el lugar o cómo y
dónde fueron eliminados las personas
responsables conocen muy bien los
detalles y ante el silencio desmedido de
arabia saudita la comunidad
internacional debe ejercer presión para
que revele los hechos frente a las
acusaciones contra bin salman el
ministerio de exteriores saudita
reaccionó a través de un comunicado
divulgado por la agencia de prensa del
reyno que califica como falsas
inaceptables e inexactas las
conclusiones del reporte